toute la communauté scientifique attend
avec fébrilité une grande annonce demain
des chercheurs de l'observatoire ligot
aux états unis auraient détecté pour la
première fois des ondes
gravitationnelles ce qui viendrait
confirmer ce qu'albert einstein avait
prédit il y a un siècle déjà pour nous
aider à comprendre tous âges accueil mon
collègue de découverte charles tisseyre
charles cette percée elle devrait être
confirmé demain une conférence de presse
de la national science foundation grosse
découverte si c'est confirmé
qu'est ce que c'est au fond saison
gravitationnelle mais les ondes
gravitationnelles ce sont comme des
vagues disons ou qui se propage dans le
cosmos et qui sont créées par des
événements cataclysmiques comme par
exemple les supernovas la formation des
trou noir ou une étoile à neutrons et
ses ongles habitationnel peuvent
parvenir jusqu'à nous einstein avait
prédit leur existence parce que pour un
style un corps massif comme une étoile
des formes l'espace qu'il appelait
l'espace temps autour de ce corps massif
et il va plus loin et dit que si cette
étoile se déplace à toute vitesse comme
deux étoiles qui vont rentrer en
collision
là elles produisent des ondes
gravitationnelles c'est un peu comme
notre main qui se bat qui balaierait la
surface d'un lac très calme et qui
formerait des ondes des vaguelettes de
part et d'autre de la main les ondes
gravitationnelles c'est la même chose
bon alors évidemment ça valait la
théorie d'einstein
mais au-delà de ça quelle est
l'importance de cette découverte qu'est
ce que ça va nous donner au fonds
jusqu'à maintenant on avait des
télescopes optiques pour voir la lumière
qui nous viennent des étoiles on avait
des radiotélescopes pour capter les
ondes radio qui viennent du cosmos des
télescope à rayons x des télescope à
rayons gamma mais là on pourra avoir des
télescopes gravitationnelle qui
capterait si son gravitationnelle et
nous permettrait de voir beaucoup plus
loin dans le cosmos est même remonté
pourquoi pas aux origines de l'univers
parce qu'à une star elle a prédit que le
big bang a créé des ondes
gravitationnelles massive qui peuvent
arriver jusqu'à nous donc de pouvoir
mieux comprendre les phénomènes qui
constitue et qui forment le cosmos et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'on ne
verrait pas ses ongles on les entendrait
le font parce que d'entendre eh oui
parce qu'elles émettent des fréquences
qui sont qui peuvent être captées par
l'oreille humaine surtout quand elles
arrivent ici ils sont très faibles
ça prend des détecteurs sophistiqués
pour les entendre mais elle émettrait
des sauts comme ça ces deux étoiles à
neutrons qui fusionne qui forment un
couloir d'après les chercheurs
bon mais comment est-ce qu'on a détecté
alors saison comment est ce qu'on a
réussi à faire faire bien il ya deux
détecteurs il ya qui sont identiques
youn en louisiane et il y en a un dans
l'état de washington
ces détecteurs sont formés de deux deux
tunnels qui sont organisées de façon
perpendiculaire comme un grand l comme
les bras et dans ces tunnels
il ya un rayon laser que l'on projette
alors einstein disait que les ondes
gravitationnelles des formes n'est ce
pas l'espace lorsqu'elle traverse un
objet donc c'est par exemple ce bras si
du détecteur en louisiane pourrait
s'allonger au passage d'une onde
l'invitational au le rayon laser à
l'intérieur pourrait détecter cette
légère ce n'est j'échange mans de la
longueur de ce mois est donc confirmé
qu'il y à une onde gravitationnelle qui
est passée par là si c'est un camion qui
a causé des vibrations ou un petit
séisme
on a un autre détecteur lui dans l'état
de washington qui confirme qu'il a
entendu l'ong habitationnel aussi et
pourtant y'a pas de camions dans l'état
de washington
ce qui prouve l'existence des ondes
gravitationnelles on va voir demain si
c'est qu'ils vont nous annoncer
oui on verra en attend ça merci beaucoup
charles de chez vous si digne